[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Today,
on Chalk Radio,
making calculus a
little less abstract.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI:
We put together
a lot of problems that
come from concepts that we
see in real life.
If it's connected with
something which is more real,
you are more willing
to work through that.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
Calculus has an
intimidating reputation,
but our guest today
has been experimenting
with creative new ways to
teach this complex subject.
Gigliola Staffilani is a
Professor of Mathematics,
and one of the lead instructors
of introductory course,
Calculus I. And she's found
that with a little help,
students often find calculus
to be more intuitive than they
first expect.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: I
feel like calculus actually
gets introduced without students
really knowing about it--
like when they
start doing algebra,
and they start talking
about functions, and also
by watching movies,
documentaries, and so on.
You often learn about
function velocity
and you learn that
there is a direction,
there is a magnitude,
which is the speed.
And it's kind of like
going to a foreign country.
And if you just live
there for a little bit,
after a couple of weeks,
you pick up a few words.
But then, it's only when
you actually take a class
that you put all this together.
SARAH HANSEN: But
sometimes, students
get stuck in translation when
moving across disciplines.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: I
think us mathematicians
like to use way less common
language like, for example,
most common notation
for a variable is x.
Sometimes, we ask y, the
function is always an f.
We just are very
familiar in using that,
and it's very common
among mathematicians.
But I realized, for
example, that it's not
a common notation for
the same kind of question
when you read books that
come from chemistry.
In math, you want
to reduce everything
to a mathematical
concept and you
don't want to be distracted
with names and maybe
cumbersome type of notation.
You just don't want
that to distract you.
But in chemistry, the
name of the variable
is important
because you probably
need to remember what that
means within a certain reaction
or something like that.
It is very hard, I
think, for a student
to, when he or she starts
taking a different class
after calculus, to realize that
actually, they know already
what they are supposed to know.
They just think that they
don't because the notation
is completely different.
SARAH HANSEN: To help
students get grounded
in the world of calculus,
Gigliola and her colleagues
have brought visual learning
methods into the classroom.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: When we
put together the calculus class
that we have on MITx,
it was very important
for us to give a
tool to the students
to actually draw pictures.
In calculus, it's very important
to understand the relationship
between the formula--
so the analysis, what we
call mathematical analysis,
so there is a formula
written with variables--
and what that
formula represents.
So for example, we can write
a line with an equation,
but we also can draw a line.
And we need to understand why
the two objects are exactly
the same, and if we
change a parameter, how
that line or other
curve changes.
SARAH HANSEN:
Sometimes, those methods
might look like a
demonstration in class.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: One
that I have used in my class
at some point, which is
really very hard to grasp,
is Lagrange multipliers.
This is a method that we
use to find maximum minimum
with constraints.
Let's think about
sphere, for example,
when you have a
surface that grows,
so the maximum radius
until the sphere touches
the boundary of a square.
When that touching happens,
then the two orthogonal vectors
are going to be parallel.
That's really what
the system tells you.
SARAH HANSEN: If, like me,
you're not a mathematician,
you might be a little lost
in all these technical terms.
But just wait until
Gigliola describes
how she turns these abstract
ideas into a physical example.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: So
I usually bring a balloon
that I start inflating in a box.
And then, when it
touches the box,
it's clear that
the side of the box
is totally tangent to
the side of my surface.
And that's where
the normal vectors
are orthogonal to each other.
So this is intuitively
visible, and it tells you
that, really, these
vectors are parallel.
And then, setting up
the system becomes
more like writing
down what it means
to have these two
vectors in a parallel way
instead of just
remembering the algorithm,
having to take all these
derivatives that equal to zero
and things like that.
So it is very
important, whenever
you have the opportunity
to visualize an object,
it is important to
do that except that,
as you become more and more
sophisticated in mathematics,
that becomes harder and harder.
But whenever you can,
anything you can use is good.
SARAH HANSEN: Gigliola
and her colleagues
have incorporated
digital applets
to bring these kinds of
visual representations
into learning experiences.
Applets are also
expanding the kinds
of problems they're able
to challenge students with.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI:
So some problems
are like a yes and no question
or like a plug-in a number.
And some other problems,
in particular in calculus,
have some kind of a complicated
formula or a drawing
or something which is not
easy to grade or to decide
whether it's correct or not.
So the sketching tool
was very important
because there are problems in
calculus in which you don't
need to be extremely
precise, but with a drawing,
you can show us whether you
understand the concept or not.
But then, of course,
my drawing might
be different than your drawing
although they're both correct,
they both reflects
what we ask you to do.
And this was a complicated
type of problem
and a very difficult
problem to grade.
So the sketching
tool, I think, gave us
a way of grading questions and
the possibility to the student
to solve questions in a way
which was exactly what we want
them to do instead of a
complicated, cumbersome way
for us to decide whether
you understand or not.
SARAH HANSEN: As she experiments
with new teaching tools
for Calculus I,
Gigliola has also
grappled with inequities in
the field of mathematics.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: We thought
about also giving the chance
to students to solve the problem
kind of like a little video
games or things like that.
But it's just really
complicated to do that.
We also thought that will have
been not a fair way of dealing
with this because--
I think there are
studies on that--
that the boys tend to do video
games or work on video games
much more than girls.
So if we set up
something like that,
then we were afraid
that the girls will not
be interested in it.
And so we decided not
to even go that way.
So to make it fair and make it
interesting for all, not just
for a category of people.
SARAH HANSEN: And
as a mother, she's
witnessed firsthand how
biases are formed years
before students even
reach the college level.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: I have
twins, a boy and a girl.
And now, they are 16.
And I witnessed from the time
they were in middle school
how different they were
treated because one was a boy,
one was a girl.
And the reaction that
they have to the way
they are treated, right?
So my son, for
example, is kind of--
I wouldn't say he
shows off, but he
likes to be thought as somebody
that picks hard classes.
And my daughter,
who is just as good
as he is and she
likes her class,
but she hides it completely.
She doesn't say that
she's taking hard classes
because that's not
considered to be
attractive for a young
woman or older woman.
Why for boys it's OK?
So there is a lot
of social pressure
and also a lot of different
reactions to the behavior
from the teachers.
So it's very acceptable
if a girl is not really
putting too much effort
in science and math,
and it's less
acceptable for boys.
So yeah, unfortunately,
from that early on,
women, young women and young
men, are treated differently.
And I think it really
takes a lot of effort
for the young women who want to
do more science and more math
because I think they just
have to go against very
high social pressure.
So then, by the time
I see them, undergrad
at MIT, we know it's
about 49% women, 51% men.
In the math department,
I think it's around 30%
women in math major.
And then, when you
go to grad school,
there are maybe 18%, 20% women.
And when you go to faculty,
well, there are four of us.
SARAH HANSEN: Is
there one small thing
that educators could do to try
to make this situation better?
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI:
Yeah, I think
being aware that they themselves
have implicit biases would
be already a big step.
And I do have implicit
biases myself.
I know that, but
I'm aware of it.
So I'm trying to go in
the opposite direction I
will actually be tempted to
go without thinking about it.
So I think being
aware of the issue,
being aware that when you ask
a question in your math class
and you might be a woman
teacher, you look at the boys
more than the girls,
which is something
that happens very often.
Being aware of that,
that's already a big step.
So next time you
try to do 50-50.
If all the problems are about
baseball players, and soccer,
and--
well, now, the girls
do soccer and they
are even better than men.
So that's great.
But there were problems that
were written 50 years ago
and they were all for boys
because those are the people
that would take those classes.
So being aware of this
and what difference
could make if you just phrase
the problem in a different way,
I think it's very important.
SARAH HANSEN: At
the end of the day,
Gigliola hopes
that students will
feel invested in the
questions they're
answering in Calculus I.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI:
We put together
a lot of problems that
come from concepts that we
see in real life.
That really helps, I think, also
in accepting the difficulties
that you face when you actually
have to solve a problem.
If it's connected with
something which is more real,
you are more willing
to work through that.
So for example, one
problem that I like,
which actually has to do with
solving some linear equations,
is a question on
how many bagels I'm
supposed to buy versus how
many croissants and how many--
if the classes want a certain--
or likes more sweets or
salty or things like that.
So it's a simple
problem, but then
when you have to translate
into math and find a solution,
you have to use relatively
sophisticated tools
to do that if there's
more than one variable.
SARAH HANSEN: With an
important outcome, too.
GIGLIOLA STAFFILANI: Yeah.
Right.
I usually bring that
stuff in this class
afterwards-- croissants,
and bagels, and donuts.
And then, I try to say,
how would you attack this?
How would you do this?
So maybe some questions
from biology or questions
from chemistry or something that
has at least a first step which
one can understand using
calculus to give you the idea
that this is not like
some abstract nonsense
that we forced you
to take at MIT,
but it's something that's
very important to, like I said
from the very beginning,
it's a language
that you need to
acquire in order
to attack any basic
question that might come up
in science in general which
has not already been answered.
Which is something
that they would
love to be in the position
of doing in your life, right?
Answer a new question.
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in teaching
with Gigliola's
calculus materials,
head over to MIT's Open
Learning library site
where you'll find her single
variable calculus MOOCs.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
MIT Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci,
and Dave Lishansky.
Our scriptwriters are Nidhi
Shastri and Aubrey Calaway.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.